the town of Mount Abu tucked in the
hills of the state of Rajasthan has been
around since the British colonial times
for more than 20 years it's been home to
go lope it's a carpenter from Germany as
a yogi meditation is part of his daily
routine another important part of his
life is the construction of this solar
thermal plant they've already put up
almost 800 scaffolds the next step is to
mount massive parabolic mirrors to
reflect the sunlight go Lopez is a
self-taught solar power expert we have a
new type of receiver which we can use to
store energy for 16 hours and we want to
make this power plant a 24 hour a day
operation which would be a world first
there's no other solar thermal power
plant that runs 24/7 the solar Park is
being partially funded by the German
government it's a model project within
the Indian government's National Solar
strategy it aims to significantly
increase the share of solar in the
country's power portfolio from less than
1% currently developers hope the new
plant will generate enough power for the
entire Brahma Kumaris spiritual
community to which Colo kids belongs
more than 20,000 believers come here on
pilgrimages several times a year but
only a few hundred people live here
permanently
the Brahma Kumaris believe they have a
special duty to the environment